italy and england will face off in the
final of the euro 2020 football
championship
at london's wembley stadium in just a
few hours this is the first final for
the england men's team in europe's top
football tournament
they're hoping to defeat italy who last
lifted the trophy
in 1968 adam rainey is standing by for
us in rome
but first let's go to paul brennan who
is at wembley stadium
where as i said the final is being held
uh paul what's the atmosphere like there
how are england fans feeling
boisterous confident as well i think
even though some of the
data crunchers put england's chances of
victory tonight at only around 53
it's a very very tight game this is
going to be we've got the best attacking
team
in the tournament uh in england against
uh sorry
in italy being the best attacking team
in the tournament versus england who are
the best defensive team they've only
conceded one goal
uh during the matches that have led up
to this final
the gates opened around 45 minutes ago
fans are already starting to stream into
the stadium over my shoulder
all of them have had to be negative show
negative coronavirus tests and the
stadium itself
only 75 full because of the covert
restrictions which are still in place
here
in the uk um only around 7 000 italy
fans
will be here a thousand of them uh
brought direct from italy in a special
almost hermetically sealed bubble um to
be
attending the game and then taken
straight back where they'll have to
quarantine the rest of those italian
fans
are actually from here in the uk sort of
expat italians
and looking at the match itself the
expectation is for a very tight game
indeed you know
italy has the experience you look at
that back to kyolina their captain 37
years old
versus the much younger england team
most of them in their mid-20s
but the two teams are have shown
themselves to be you know
really the match for anything that
they've come up against so far
and the expectation for the wider
country well i'll show you the front
page of the sunday times here which
pretty much sums it up that's the
captain harry kane
that's in georgia's flag across the
front of it
and uh yeah now it's a bit it's a bit
creased because it's
it's been folded but yeah the
expectation in the wider country as well
enormous the feeling is basically if if
this
if this isn't england's time then
frankly when is they've had home
advantage for most of the matches
um they've got this great squad of
players and frankly to have made it
through to the final
at this time with those advantages it
really should be england's time
and paul if you don't mind passing on to
the teams there i want a nice clean game
i don't want any penalty shootouts i
don't think that my nerves can take it
pass that on for me would you let's go
to adam rainey now uh who is standing by
for us
in rome adam tell us how are italy fans
preparing
well kim much like what paul said about
the fans there in london there's a
certain buoyancy here
just a few hundred meters from where i'm
staying at the coliseum one of the
the few nodes or gathering spots for
fans
is opened up and people are starting to
file in some 2500 people can attend
there there's another one across
from us another part of the center where
another 2500 fans must have tickets to
get
in they're not going in with any covet
testing as is happening
at wembley but what we're seeing is
concern across the country
that this event with these big screen
televisions and gathering points across
the country
could help push the delta variant
into full force here i haven't seen as
many cases of course here in italy as
you have seen in the uk
so people are hopeful they think it's
their time although they don't have the
drought
that the english side has they feel that
in 2018
not making the world cup finals was a
huge
pain an opening wound actually here in
italy and they see
this kind of 33-game streak of
undefeated plays against
internationals right now is this proof
that they're on the upward
trajectory and also on the same day that
they're going to face off against
england for this title for the european
title they have
a beloved tennis player mateo bertini
the first italian
ever to make it into a singles fine on
wimbledon he's currently playing against
the world number one djokovic
it's unclear how that's going to shake
out but there's this sense in the air
that this is italy's
moment after a very hard year from cove
of course the whole world has had a hard
year but italians
like to have a little drama and think
since they were the first western
country to suffer so bad from it
that this is some sort of redemption for
them and they also see that they're
fighting for the whole european union
they point out that the the chief
executive of the european union ursula
uh uh the line she says that
she have underlined she herself has said
she support an italian side and many see
this as a strong response
to brexit that all of europe is now
fighting for italy to win out whether
that's going to make a difference it's
not clear
but that's how people see things here
kim all right hey thank you very much
for that uh adam rainey live
from wrong